all right so this is how the kleptocracy
works we actually have a really great
example now that we can look at Donald
Trump was so outraged that his friend
Roger stone who depending on when you
asked him he barely knows was to be
sentenced for possibly seven to nine
years that he personally intervened and
all of a sudden the sentencing
recommendations have been changed the
prosecutors have quit in in a fury and
we have ourselves a very nice little
case study in the unhinged the even more
unhinged Trump that we can expect to see
if he gets reelected to another first to
another four years so the way that it
went down is that Trump went crazy on
Twitter clearly tampered with the
justice system and Roger stone now is
going to get himself a far shorter
prison sentence for his crimes
federal prosecutors told the court
Monday that seven to nine years is the
right range that they would like to see
for the crimes that Roger stone
committed and was convicted of which are
witness tampering and lying to Congress
now remember the prosecutors make a
recommendation the defense will get a
chance to state its case and ultimately
a judge will decide what the sentence is
going to be Trump went nuts at the mere
recommendation from the prosecutors
tweeting quote this is a horrible and
very unfair situation the real crimes
were on the other side as nothing
happens to them cannot allow this
miscarriage of justice now understand
that when Donald Trump is referring to
people on the other side he's talking
about people who haven't been charged
with a crime haven't been tried and
certainly haven't been convicted of
anything
so Trump is saying the fact that people
who I believe did something wrong but
who haven't even been accused of
anything by the justice system the fact
that they aren't going to prison is a
justification for Roger stone going to
prison for a far shorter amount of time
this is crazy
authoritarian
this is the stuff of dictators now
following Donald Trump's
middle-of-the-night tweet which he sent
right around 2:00 a.m. on Tuesday
morning the Justice Department suddenly
decides we're going to overrule the
prosecutors who are recommending seven
to nine years according to Huffington
Post all four federal prosecutors who
ran the Roger stone trial then abruptly
dropped out of the case on Tuesday after
senior Department of Justice leadership
intervened to take the rare step of
walking back the prosecutors sentencing
recommendation this is not normal this
gets us to Tuesday afternoon and as
HuffPost says the US Attorney's Office
for DC filed a new recommendation asking
that stone who is of course a Trump
advisor be sentenced to prison but not
suggesting any particular length of time
don't be tricked by Trump or anybody
around him this is very irregular this
is our justice system being subjugated
by the Oval Office for political reasons
successfully the prosecutors are
resigning and this is the unhinged Trump
that we predicted because he gets away
with everything and it's going to get
much worse if he is reelected
we know that Trump's acquittal from
impeachment has emboldened him
we know that Trump essentially getting
away with everything in the Moller
investigation has emboldened him he will
do whatever he wants and why wouldn't he
he's gotten away with everything that
he's tried they are purging legal
truth-telling impeachment witnesses we
talked about that Monday this includes
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander VIN Minh
this includes ambassador to the European
Union Gordon Sunland and now they're
telling the Justice Department shorter
prison sentences please and they're not
saying please just imagine if Donald
Trump wins re-election nothing will hold
them back this is how we continue the
authoritarian slide we have to stop it
in November this story if it were under
Obama if it were under any other
presidency it would be wall-to-wall
coverage for days the incredible
overreach by the Oval Office but it's
barely a blip it got a little
coverage we had the New Hampshire
primary around the same time okay this
is just the beginning if Donald Trump
gets himself reelected in November do
you feel like you just don't have enough
time to become as intellectually
well-rounded as you would like to be
that they're just not enough hours in
your week for you to read all of the
books that you want to read one of our
sponsors is called blinka stand it's an
app that lets you consume an entire
nonfiction book in 15 minutes it's only
about eight bucks a month but you can
try it for free for a week and get 25%
off a subscription
when you go to blankest comm slash
Pakman what blinka studs is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and condense them into either text or
audio that you can read or listen to in
just 15 minutes and what you get is all
of the most important ideas and
information from the book imagine being
able to listen to an entire nonfiction
book in the amount of time it takes you
to drive or walk home from work
I've just finished listening to upheaval
by Jared Diamond Jared Diamond a
tremendous author whose work I've
previously recommended excellent book
looking at some of modern history's
biggest national crises to figure out
how different countries ended up in such
precarious situations Blinky's has
totally transformed how I consume
information I love it of course I read a
book in its entirety when I can but
there are simply just so many books that
I want to read and would not have the
time for if it weren't for blinka stay
they have books on politics economics
philosophy science you name it you can
try it out yourself totally free for a
week and get 25% off if you decide to
subscribe just by going to blink is comm
slash Pakman I've put the link right
underneath this video like the rest of
us I bet you're going into 2020 thinking
about what you didn't get around to in
2019 and your goals for the new year if
you want to work towards being your best
self in 2020 understand more about the
world around you and make sure that your
time is well spent then blink astiz for
you